RENE MARSH REPORTS FROM A
NATIONAL PARK ON THE EAST COAST
THAT'S VANISHING DUE TO THE
CLIMATE DISASTER CAUSED BY
HUMANS.
>> Reporter: THE LAND IS
DISAPPEARING BEFORE OUR EYES.
MARILYN'S EASTERN SHORES IN THE
CROSSHAIRS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INDUCED SEA LEVEL RISE.
AND SO IS THE RICH HISTORY
PRESERVED AT THE HARRIET TUBMAN
UNDERGROUND RAILROAD NATIONAL
HISTORICAL PARK.
>> WE ARE WEARING THESE NETS
BECAUSE SO MUCH WATER HERE.
IT'S STANDING WATER.
THE MOSQUITOES ARE REALLY BAD.
>> Reporter: THE MOSQUITOES ARE
BAD.
SO THIS IS ALMOST LIKE A
REQUIREMENT DURING THE SUMMER?
>> IF HARRIET TUBMAN WERE LIVING
NOW, SHE WOULD RECOGNIZE THIS
LANDSCAPE, BUT SHE WOULD BE
SHOCKED AT HOW QUICKLY IT'S
DISAPPEARING.
>> Reporter: AS WATER FROM THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY ENROACHES,
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND
SCIENTISTS PROJECT LARGE
PORTIONS OF THE NATIONAL PARK
WILL BE UNDERWATER BY THE YEAR
2050 IF PLANET WARMING EMISSIONS
ARE NOT DRASTICALLY CURBED.
RISING TIDES THREATEN PLACES
LIKE THIS CEMETERY FOR FREED
BLACK PEOPLE IN TUBMAN'S
COMMUNITY.
>> THESE LOW-LYING AREAS THAT
WERE A PART OF THE IMPORTANT
TRAILS THAT ALLOWED PEOPLE TO
ESCAPE AT THAT TIME WILL BE LOST
IN SOME PLACES.
>> Reporter: MORE THAN 70% OF
NATIONAL PARKS IN THE
CONTINENTAL U.S. ARE AT HIGH
RISK FROM THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE AND FLOODING
TO EXTREME TEMPERATURES, DROUGHT
AND WILDFIRES.
HISTORIC FLOODING AT YELLOWSTONE
NATIONAL PARK LAST MONTH FORCED
IT TO SHUT DOWN FOR MORE THAN A
WEEK.
CALIFORNIA'S SEQUOIA NATIONAL
PARK, HOME OF THE WORLD'S
LARGEST TREES, WILDFIRES HAVE
BURNED LARGE SWATHS OF THE GIANT
SEQUOIA GROWTHS.
WILDFIRES AND EXTREME HEAT HAVE
FORCED CALIFORNIA'S YOSEMITE
NATIONAL PARK TO CLOSE SEVERAL
TIMES IN RECENT YEARS.
MEANWHILE, GLACIER NATIONAL PARK
IN MONTANA IS RAPIDLY LOSING ITS
NAMESAKE FEATURE.
THIS IS THE GLACIER IN 1910
VERSUS 2021.
>> THESE ARE PLACES THAT TELL
CRITICAL STORIES OF OUR HISTORY
AND PEOPLE AND CULTURE, AND
THESE PLACES ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO WITHSTAND THESE REPEAT
ASSAULTS.
>> Reporter: MORE FREQUENT, MORE
INTENSE NATURAL DISASTERS WILL
DRASTICALLY TRANSFORM NATIONAL
PARK LANDSCAPES AND THERE'S THE
ECONOMIC LOSS.
>> IN 2021 ALONE, OUR NATIONAL
PARKS SAW OVER 297 MILLION
VISITORS.
THEY GENERATED OVER
$42.5 BILLION.
>> Reporter: BACK ON MARYLAND'S
EASTERN SHORE, THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE SAYS IT IS TEAMED UP
WITH THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
AND THE NATIONAL OCEANIC AND
ATMOSPHERIC ASSOCIATION TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND IT IS HIGH TIDE HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND YOU CAN
SEE WATER IS FLOWING OVER THE
BANKS HERE AT THE JEFFERSON
MEMORIAL.
IN PART BECAUSE WATER LEVELS
HAVE RISEN A FOOT SINCE THIS
MEMORIAL WAS BUILT 75 YEARS AGO,
AND THIS ISSUE OF CLIMATE IN
NATIONAL PARKS IS ON THE RADAR
FOR SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THIS WEEK MEMBERS VISITED
YOSEMITE NATIONAL PARK TO SEE
FIRSTHAND THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON THESE NATIONAL PAR